oh boy the gloves are coming off
President Trump
lashing out in his ongoing feud with
Nancy Pelosi the president delivering a
blistering response after the House
Speaker reportedly told leading
Democrats
she doesn't want Trump impeached she
wants to see him in prison Nancy Pelosi
is a disaster okay she's a disaster and
let her do what she wants you know what
I think they're in big trouble because
when you look at the kind of crimes that
were committed and I don't need any more
evidence and I guess from what I'm
hearing there's a lot of evidence coming
in I've tried to be nice to her because
I would have liked to have gotten some
deals done she's incapable of doing
deals she's a nasty vindictive horrible
person the Muller report came out it was
a disaster for them she made a statement
who's a horrible when you asked the
vicious statement while I'm overseas no
if I made any statement about anybody it
would be like a big hug why would he do
that when he's over said she is a
terrible person and I'll tell you her
name it's nervous Nancy because she's a
nervous wreck
Wow so Jesse today then the president
followed up with a tweet I think we have
it here in which he talks about not
impeachment but again
going to jail so I'm thinking to myself
hmm he says there there's no evidence to
justify having Nancy Pelosi make such a
statement but I'm thinking is going to
jail on his mind is he scared yeah one
Trump looks nervous doesn't he why he
looks not yeah you think she's gonna go
to jail yeah he's not going to jail one
and nervous Nancy is like top five
nickname and that's gonna stick I just
want to address the elephant please
please Greg is in a panic he's a driving
test on Monday and he just found out
it's not in the country it's in a city
and this man is sweating bullets he's
gonna record it in case someone tries to
sabotage him for political purposes the
man is paranoid I don't think he's gonna
make it through the show
I'm only saying I'm anxious because
somebody in my ear producer said that
the the prompter operator was flunked
twice at this location I don't need to
know that
that at 4:59 yes at 4:59 before the show
started nervous correct my mother made
me drive a stick-shift and learn in a
trucker's parking lot and that was so
embarrassing that I learned right away
wouldn't believe what I've learned in a
talk about going to jail that's just
nonsense by the way I'm looking at the
president there with talking Laura
Ingraham and I'm thinking you know Dana
worked for the White House they don't
understands the power of the office and
symbolism there is in this normandy
graveyard and he's going on attack and
Pete I just thought well he was asked
questions and when the president's asked
questions he answers them and you're
free to ask any question as well I think
you could have said come back next week
when I'm back at the White House we can
talk about all of this if you wanted to
but Nancy Pelosi she's there at the
cemetery as well somebody shouts a
question I'm not gonna do that overseas
however I don't think that she was too
upset that the article was printed back
home in Politico saying that she at the
Democratic meeting said she'd rather see
him in prison because it made her look
tough and she likes to dribble these
things out there because she thinks it
rattles him now he wants to counterpunch
and look location being what it is he
could look at it could be on Twitter
this is a few that is going to go on
forever I feel like just every hour you
could get something else fact just last
hour we found out that Bruce or who
worked at the Justice Department who was
demoted before he left the Justice
Department he was given 48 thousand
dollars in bonus money yeah interesting
okay so like there's these little drips
and drabs that come out I'm just saying
that there there's something every day
that you can pick apart on this thing
the other thing is the US Attorney John
Durham that's working on the
investigation of the investigators
apparently he was it was said to our own
catherine herridge that he's asking all
of the right questions i don't know what
that means but it's enough to get this
story going for another three days until
you have John Dean testifying in front
of the House on Monday it never stops
so Greg let's come back to impeachment
let's forget the jail stuff first
and the president says there's no
evidence you know he doesn't understand
it and yet the New York Times today is
printing an article in which it says
well here's what articles of impeachment
might look like and here they're talking
about lying obstruction financial
impropriety what do you make of it well
okay use the Times op-ed shows you how
the media has become essentially a
bathhouse of mutual massage they're in
this bubble what the New York Times is
writing for the activists on Twitter the
Twitter activists are tweeting to get
the attention of the New York Times
meanwhile the rest of the world goes on
when you look at you know again
historical unemployment you see progress
on various fronts I mean obviously we
can talk about terror you can talk about
trade you can talk about jobs you can
talk about the economy all of these
deeds as opposed to words but the times
it can't look at that because that
destroys their entire narrative can I
talk about nervous Nancy since by the
way it is a great nickname because you
can use it on anybody like nervous Nancy
now replaces nervous Nellie so you're
too young to know nervous Nellie but you
were or negative Nancy I am a nervous
I'm a nervous Nancy I am I am I feel
like a nervous Nancy and to your point
which I understand about the I think
that there was a juxtaposition there
with the rows and rows of the dead and
this is a week when we're honoring those
people but for when you're being
interviewed you you aren't thinking
about what's behind you most of the time
when you're being interviewed and I
think that the juxtaposition is
interesting because back at that time
they were dodging grenades being hurled
at them and here it's just insults and
so maybe the juxtaposition ironically
talks about how we're in a lucky better
time because of those rows and rows of
dead behind him so I don't know it's a
it's kind of an interesting thing and
it's it's it's an odd place to have an
interview but you're sensitive so I
thought it was me
being sensitive to it because I robert
muller actually a former Marine Vietnam
veteran and I just thought hmm is this
the place to do it I don't think there
should be any interviews there okay
that's how I feel all right Katie as the
president comes home he's gonna face a
lot of issues we see some kind of I'm
sorry
the economic numbers the Fed is talking
about maybe the need to pump up or lower
actually interest rates what do you
think and of course he's got the battle
with Republicans in the Senate over the
use of tariffs on the immigration issues
well I think the economy is doing just
fine
based on the track record the Trump
administration has had up until this
point but in terms of working with Nancy
Pelosi on big things like infrastructure
or immigration I think Democrats are
missing a big opportunity here because
we President Trump went into the Oval
Office he wasn't a hard partisan in fact
he you could argue he was an independent
run on a Republican ticket and he had
donated to Democrats and Republicans for
all kinds of causes he had been open
about the fact that he wanted to do
infrastructure during the campaign there
are things that Democrats actually could
work with President Trump on to regain a
lot of those blue-collar workers that
people like Joe Biden are trying to
regain and yet because of this constant
feud that's not happening I think
Democrats are really you know missing
their chance to get a lot of this done
or at least talk about it and why it's
important but one more thing on Nancy
Pelosi look she made this comment the
president's asked about it is he not
allowed to respond just because he's
overseas when the comment was made while
he was overseas they still don't
understand this dynamic of he's accused
of something and then when he responds
he's the one who's in the wrong allowed
to respond to allegations or accusations
anymore yeah you know you could argue
that the president has been classier
when it comes to his treatment of Nancy
Pelosi he came in and assuming office he
had very nice things to say about Nancy
and Chuck and told me when I interviewed
him he's looking forward to negotiating
with them and they thinks they're great
people and he's tried to do that a
several times and he's met with them and
he's tried to bring them on board on
bipartisan issues like renegotiating
NAFTA or fixing the immigration crisis
but time and time again
he's been sabotage by Nancy and then she
says dirty nasty things just to us wage
her caucus because she's lost control
and I think it looks like he's had it
well I feel for the country if you look
at the way that Chuck Schumer reacts and
the way that Nancy Pelosi reacts they do
these pressors together after these
meetings but Chuck Schumer is actually
much
reserved when it comes to what he's
saying about the president he's actually
praising the President on China for
example whereas Nancy Pelosi is you know
catering to the far left of her party
and doesn't come to the middle at all
when Chuck Schumer's reaction has been a
little more muted even if not oh I just
think just to sum it up for me
better to have insult wars than real
wars that's true well I Amen